rabbiner aus afghanistan hat ein
geheimnis
ich kann dir meinen namen noch den
meiner familie schreiben auch bei man
kann kaum lesen und schreiben
ich bin zwei jahre zur schule gegangen
dann habe ich als frisörin gearbeitet
und dann war ich hausfrau hbb und
peymann gehören zu den frauen für die es
besonders schwer ist sich in deutschland
zu integrieren
peymann ist 23 jahre und kurden aus dem
irak mit 14 wurde sie verheiratet sie
wohnt mit ihrem mann und drei
schulpflichtigen kindern in einem
wohnheim in köln
meistens bleibt die familie unter sich
ich habe keine deutschen freundinnen ich
kenne nur einen spanier
ich wünsche mir deutsche freunde aber
bisher hatte ich keine chance
auch abb hat kaum kontakt zu deutschen
familien nur eine deutsche frau hat sie
im wohnheim kennengelernt
wir sind seit einem jahr mit ihr
befreundet wenn wir probleme haben oder
briefe bekommen von den behörden hilft
sie uns
wir machen dann einen termin meine
tochter trifft sich mit ihr und bringt
die briefe mit
und wenn wir zum arbeitsamt gehen müssen
dann begleitet sie uns sie hilft uns
sehr und wir sind ihr sehr dankbar
dennoch fühlen sich die 44 jährige witwe
habe und ihre kinder nicht integriert
sie leben in einem ganz eigenen
kulturellen umfeld jenseits der
deutschen gesellschaft
mit sogenannten niedrigschwelligen
alphabetisierungskursen versucht die
deutsche politik an die vielen frauen
heranzukommen
die hier gewissermaßen unter dem radar
leben wir wollen den frauen überhaupt
ermöglichen dass sie aus der wohnung aus
deren häusern raus gehen auf die straße
gehen dass sie die umgebung kennen
lernen dass sie deutsch lernen dass sie
andere frauen kennen werden dass sie
einfach kontakt haben und sich dann auch
frei bewegen können die kurse werden vom
bundesamt für migration und flüchtlinge
angeboten
ein erster schritt der aber nicht
ausreiche mahnen experten
ich glaube dass das nicht reicht man
muss für eine gelingende integration vor
allem die kinder im blick haben und
dafür ganz bestimmt auch die mitte sehr
viele der zuwanderer die jetzt zu uns
kommen und gekommen sind sind muslime
die väter sind sozusagen im sinne des
altrömischen pater familias die die den
ton angeben und oft ihre frauen im
hintergrund halten wir versuchen ja
gerade durch diese niederschwelligen
frauenkurse die frauen zu erreichen und
es wäre sehr hilfreich wenn diese
denkstrukturen auch geändert werden aber
machen wir uns nichts vor
das geht nicht von heute auf morgen das
dauert das ein langwieriger prozess um
diese kurse traten tun leisten einen
beitrag dazu
[Musik]
seit 2015 sind mehr als eine million
flüchtlinge nach deutschland gekommen
die mittel für niedrigschwellige
angebote wurden verdreifacht auf mehr
als zwei millionen euro im jahr 2017
das reicht aber nur für eine erste
orientierung im neuen kulturkreis doch
viele frauen kommen darüber hinaus auch
bei christian reder war das lange so die
kurdinnen ist vor 17 jahren nach
deutschland gekommen
zusammen mit ihrem mann und zwei söhnen
ihr mann war dagegen dass sie einen
integrationskurs besucht irgendwann hat
sie sich entschieden aus der isolation
auszubrechen
sie hat deutsch gelernt und kümmert sich
nun selbst um migrantinnen sie
beobachtet dass viele überfordert sind
und gehemmt viele frauen haben hier
keine lust zum lernen aber viele frauen
die schon lange her ist die grünen fast
denn bei deutsch oder auch was ihm
später war die wollen nicht sprechen
gestern hat es viel mut gekostet sich
aktiv in die neue gesellschaft zu
integrieren und die isolation hinter
sich zu lassen
sie hat sich hilfe gesucht bei der
caritas doch damit mehr frauen so
handeln müsste auch die deutsche politik
aktiver gesicht zeigen gegenüber den
herkunfts kulturen sagen experten
das wird zu kollisionen für mit den
familiären vorgaben von zu hause diese
kollisionen sollte der staat hier durch
stehen auch zumutungen an die eltern und
sogar an die kinder durch stehen und das
ziel einer vernünftigen
zivilgesellschaftlichen integration im
blick behalten
dafür könnten sie der schlüssel sein
denn peymann habe und die anderen frauen
wollen in deutschland bleiben wollen
dass ihre kinder hier aufwachsen